suppose I give you two different lists
of numbers or maybe two different
functions and I ask you to think of all
the ways you might combine those two
lists to get a new list of numbers or
combine the two functions to get a new
function
maybe one simple way that comes to mind
is to Simply add them together term by
term likewise with the functions you can
add all the corresponding outputs in a
similar vein you could also multiply the
two lists term by term and do the same
thing with the functions but there's
another kind of combination just as
fundamental as both of those but a lot
less commonly discussed known as a
convolution but unlike the previous two
cases it's not something that's merely
inherited from an operation you can do
to numbers it's something genuinely new
for the context of list of numbers or
combining functions they show up all
over the place they are ubiquitous in
image processing it's a core construct
in the theory of probability they're
used a lot in solving differential
equations and one context where you've
almost certainly seen it if not by this
name is multiplying two polynomials
together as someone in the business of
visual explanations this is an
especially great topic because the
formulaic definition in isolation and
without context can look kind of
intimidating but if we take the time to
really unpack what it's saying and
before that actually motivate why you
would want something like this it's an
incredibly beautiful operation and I
have to admit I actually learned a
little something while putting together
the visuals for this project in the case
of convolving two different functions I
was trying to think of different ways
you might picture what that could mean
and with one of them I had a little bit
of an aha moment for why it is that
normal distributions play the role that
they do in probability why it's such a
natural shape for a function but I'm
getting ahead of myself there's a lot of
setup for that one in this video our
primary focus is just going to be on the
discrete case and in particular building
up to a very unexpected but very clever
algorithm for computing these and I'll
pull out the discussion for the
continuous case into a second part
it's very tempting to open up with the
image processing examples since they're
visually the most intriguing but there
are a couple bits of finickiness that
make the image processing case less
representative of convolutions overall
so instead let's kick things off with
probability and in particular one of the
simplest examples that I'm sure everyone
here has thought about at some point in
their life which is rolling a pair of
dice and figuring out the chances of
seeing various different sums
and you might say not a problem not a
problem each of your two dice has six
different possible outcomes which gives
us a total of 36 distinct possible pairs
of outcomes and if we just look through
them all we can count up how many pairs
have a given sum and arranging all the
pairs in a grid like this one pretty
nice thing is that all of the pairs that
have a constant sum are visible along
one of these different diagonals so
simply counting how many exist on each
of those diagonals will tell you how
likely you are to see a particular sum
and I'd say very good very good but can
you think of any other ways that you
might visualize the same question other
images that can come to mind to think of
all the distinct pairs that have a given
sum
and maybe one of you raises your hand
and says yeah I've got one let's say you
picture these two different sets of
possibilities each in a row but you flip
around that second row that way all of
the different pairs which add up to
seven line up vertically like this
and if we slide that bottom row all the
way to the right then the unique pair
that adds up to two the snake eyes are
the only ones that align and if I shrunk
that over one unit to the right the
pairs which align are the two different
pairs that add up to three
and in general different offset values
of this lower array which remember I had
to flip around first reveal all the
distinct pairs that have a given sum
as far as probability questions go this
still isn't especially interesting
because all we're doing is counting how
many outcomes there are in each of these
categories but that is with the implicit
assumption that there's an equal chance
for each of these faces to come up but
what if I told you I have a special set
of dice that's not uniform maybe the
blue die has its own set of numbers
describing the probabilities for each
face coming up and the red die has its
own unique distinct set of numbers in
that case if you wanted to figure out
say the probability of seeing a 2 you
would multiply the probability that the
blue die is a one times the probability
that the red die is of one and for the
chances of seeing a 3 you look at the
two distinct pairs where that's possible
and again multiply the corresponding
probabilities and then add those two
products together similarly the chances
of seeing a 4 involves multiplying
together three different pairs of
possibilities and adding them all
together and in the spirit of setting up
some formulas let's name these top
probabilities A1 A2 A3 and so on and
name the bottom ones B1 b2b2 3 and so on
and in general this process where we're
taking two different arrays of numbers
flipping the second one around and then
lining them up at various different
offset values taking a bunch of pairwise
products and adding them up that's one
of the fundamental ways to think about
what a convolution is
so just to spell it out a little more
exactly through this process we just
generated probabilities for seeing 2 3 4
on and on up to 12. and we got them by
mixing together one list of values a and
another list of values B in the lingo
we'd say the convolution of those two
sequences gives us this new sequence the
new sequence of 11 values each of which
looks like some sum of pairwise products
if you prefer another way you could
think about the same operation is to
First create a table of all the pairwise
products and then add up along all these
diagonals again that's a way of mixing
together these two sequences of numbers
to get us a new sequence of 11 numbers
it's the same operation as the sliding
Windows thought just another perspective
putting a little notation to it here's
how you might see it written down the
convolution of A and B denoted with this
little asterisk is a new list and the
nth element of that list looks like a
sum and that sum goes over all different
pairs of indices I and J so that the sum
of those indices is equal to n it's kind
of a mouthful but for example if n was
six the pairs we're going over are one
and five two and four three and three
four and two five and one all the
different pairs that add up to six
but honestly however you write it down
the notation is secondary in importance
to the visual you might hold in your
head for the process
here maybe it helps to do a super simple
example where I might ask you what's the
convolution of the list one two three
with the list four five six
they might picture taking both of these
lists flipping around that second one
and then starting with its lid all the
way over to the left then the pair of
values which align are 1 and 4 multiply
them together and that gives us our
first term of our output it's like that
bottom array one unit to the right the
pairs which align are one five and two
and four multiply those pairs add them
together and that gives us Thirteen the
next entry in our output slide things
over once more and we'll take one times
six plus two times five plus three times
four which happens to be 28 one more
slide and we get two times six plus
three times five and that gives us 27
and finally the last term will look like
three times six if you'd like you can
pull up whatever your favorite
programming languages and your favorite
library that includes various numerical
operations and you can confirm I'm not
lying to you if you take the convolution
of one two three against four five six
this is indeed the result that you'll
get
we've seen one case where this is a
natural and desirable operation adding
up two probability distributions and
another common example would be a moving
average imagine you have some long list
of numbers and you take another smaller
list of numbers that all add up to one
in this case I just have a little list
of five values and they're all equal to
one-fifth then if we do this sliding
window convolution process and kind of
close our eyes and sweep under the rug
what happens at the very beginning of it
once our smaller list of values entirely
overlaps with the bigger one think about
what each term in this convolution
really means at each iteration what
you're doing is multiplying each of the
values from your data by one-fifth and
adding them all together which is to say
you're taking an average of your data
inside this little window
overall the process gives you a smoothed
out version of the original data and you
could modify this starting with a
different little list of numbers and as
long as that little list all adds up to
one you can still interpret it as a
moving average in the example shown here
that moving average would be giving more
weight towards the central value this
also results in a smoothed out version
of the data
if you do kind of a two-dimensional
analog of this it gives you a fun
algorithm for blurring a given image and
I should say the animations I'm about to
show are modified from something I
originally made for part of a set of
lectures I did with the Julia Lab at MIT
for a certain open courseware class that
included an image Processing Unit there
we did a little bit more to dive into
the code behind all of this so if you're
curious I'll leave you some links but
focusing back on this blurring example
what's going on is I've got this little
3x3 grid of values that's marching along
our original image and if we zoom in
each one of those values is 1 9 and what
I'm doing at each iteration is
multiplying each of those values by the
corresponding pixel that it sits on top
of and of course in computer science we
think of colors as little vectors of
three values representing the red green
and blue components when I multiply all
these little values by 1 9 and I add
them together it gives us an average
along each color Channel and the
corresponding pixel for the image on the
right is defined to be that sum the
overall effect as we do this for every
single Pixel on the image is that each
one kind of bleeds into all of its
neighbors which gives us a blurrier
version than the original
in the lingo we'd say that the image on
the right is a convolution of our
original image with a little grid of
values or more technically maybe I
should say that it's the convolution
with a 180 degree rotated version of
that little grid of values not that it
matters when the grid is symmetric but
it's just worth keeping in mind that the
definition of a convolution as inherited
from the pure math context should always
invite you to think about flipping
around that second array if we modify
this slightly we can get a much more
elegant blurring effect by choosing a
different grid of values in this case I
have a little five by five grid but the
distinction is not so much its size if
we zoom in we notice that the value in
the middle is a lot bigger than the
value towards the edges and where this
is coming from is they're all sampled
from a bell curve known as a gaussian
distribution
that way when we multiply all of these
values by the corresponding pixel that
they're sitting on top of we're giving a
lot more weight to that Central pixel
and much less towards the ones out at
the edge and just as before the
corresponding pixel on the right is
defined to be this sum as we do this
process for every single Pixel it gives
a blurring effect which much more
authentically simulates the notion of
putting your lens out of focus or
something like that but blurring is far
from the only thing that you can do with
this idea for instance take a look at
this little grid of values which involve
some positive numbers on the left and
some negative numbers on the right which
I'll color with blue and red
respectively take a moment to see if you
can predict and understand what effect
this will have on the final image
so in this case I'll just be thinking of
the image as grayscale instead of
colored so each of the pixels is just
represented by one number instead of
three and one thing worth noticing is
that as we do this convolution it's
possible to get Negative values for
example at this point here if we zoom in
the left half of our little grid sits
entirely on top of black pixels which
would have a value of zero but the right
half of negative values all sit on top
of white pixels which would have a value
of one so when we multiply corresponding
terms and add them together the results
will be very negative and the way I'm
displaying this with the image on the
right is to color negative values red
and positive values blue another thing
to notice is that when you're on a patch
that's all the same color everything
goes to zero since the sum of the values
in our little grid is zero
this is very different from the previous
two examples where the sum of our little
grid was 1 which let us interpret it as
a moving average and hence a blur
all in all this little process basically
detects wherever there's variation in
the pixel value As you move from left to
right and so it gives you a kind of way
to pick up on all the vertical edges
from your image
and similarly if we rotated that grid
around so that it varies As you move
from the top to the bottom this will be
picking up on all the horizontal edges
which in the case of our little pie
creature image does result in some
pretty demonic eyes
this smaller grid by the way is often
called a kernel and the beauty here is
how just by choosing a different kernel
you can get different image processing
effects not just blurring or Edge
detection but also things like
sharpening for those of you who have
heard of a convolutional neural network
the idea there is to use data to figure
out what the kernels should be in the
first place as determined by whatever
the neural network wants to detect
another thing I should maybe bring up is
the length of the output for something
like the moving average example you
might only want to think about the terms
when both of the windows fully align
with each other or in the image
processing example maybe you want the
final output to have the same size as
the original now convolutions as a pure
math operation always produce an array
that's bigger than the two arrays that
you started with at least assuming one
of them doesn't have a length of one
just know that in certain computer
science contexts you often want to
deliberately truncate that output
Another Thing Worth highlighting is that
in the computer science context this
notion of flipping around that kernel
before you let it march across the
original often feels really weird and
just uncalled for but again note that
that's what's inherited from the pure
math context where like we saw with the
probabilities it's an incredibly natural
thing to do and actually I can show you
one more pure math example where even
the programmers should care about this
one because it opens the doors for a
much faster algorithm to compute all of
these to set up what I mean by faster
here let me go back and pull up some
python again and I'm going to create two
different relatively big arrays each one
will have a hundred thousand random
elements in it and I'm going to assess
the runtime of the convolve function
from the numpyte library and in this
case it runs it for multiple different
iterations tries to find an average and
it looks like on this computer at least
it averages at 4.87 seconds by contrast
if I use a different function from the
scipy library called fft convolve which
is the same thing just implemented
differently that only takes 4.3
milliseconds on average so three orders
of magnitude Improvement and again even
though it flies under a different name
it's giving the same output that the
other convolved function does is just
doing something to go about it in a
cleverer way
remember how with the probability
example I said another way you could
think about the convolution was to
create this table of all the pairwise
products and then add up those pairwise
products along the diagonals
there's of course nothing specific to
probability anytime you're convolving
two different list of numbers you can
think about it this way create this kind
of multiplication table with all
pairwise products and then each Sum
along the diagonal corresponds to one of
your final outputs
one context where this view is
especially natural is when you multiply
together two polynomials for example let
me take the little grid we already have
and replace the top terms with one two x
and three x squared and replace the
other terms with 4 5x and 6X squared now
think about what it means when we're
creating all of these different pairwise
products between the two lists what
you're doing is essentially expanding
out the full product of the two
polynomials I have written down and then
when you add up along the diagonal that
corresponds to collecting all like terms
which is pretty neat expanding a
polynomial and collecting like terms is
exactly the same process as a
convolution
but this allows us to do something
that's pretty cool because think about
what we're saying here we're saying if
you take two different functions and you
multiply them together which is a simple
pointwise operation that's the same
thing as if you had first extracted the
coefficients from each one of those
assuming they're polynomials and then
taken a convolution of those two lists
of coefficients what makes that so
interesting is that convolutions feel in
principle a lot more complicated than
simple multiplication and I don't just
mean conceptually they're harder to
think about I mean computationally it
requires more steps to perform a
convolution than it does to perform a
point-wise product of two different
lists
for example let's say I gave you two
really big polynomials say each one with
a hundred different coefficients then if
the way you multiply them was to expand
out this product you know filling in
this entire 100 by 100 grid of pairwise
products that would require you to
perform 10 000 different products and
then when you're collecting all the like
terms along the diagonals that's another
set of around 10 000 operations more
generally in the lingo we'd say the
algorithm is O of N squared meaning for
two lists of size n the way that the
number of operations scales is in
proportion to the square of n
on the other hand if I think of two
polynomials in terms of their outputs
for example sampling their values at
some handful of inputs then multiplying
them only requires as many operations as
the number of samples since again it's a
pointwise operation and with polynomials
you only need finitely many samples to
be able to recover the coefficients for
example two outputs are enough to
uniquely specify a linear polynomial
three outputs would be enough to
uniquely specify a quadratic polynomial
and in general if you know n distinct
outputs that's enough to uniquely
specify a polynomial that has n
different coefficients or if you prefer
we could phrase this in the language of
systems of equations imagine I tell you
I have some polynomial but I don't tell
you what the coefficients are those are
a mystery to you in our example you
might think of this as the product that
we're trying to figure out and then
suppose I say I'll just tell you what
the outputs of this polynomial would be
if you inputted various different inputs
like 0 1 2 3 on and on and I give you
enough so that you have as many any
equations as you have unknowns it even
happens to be a linear system of
equations so that's nice and in
principle at least this should be enough
to recover the coefficients so the rough
algorithm outline then would be whenever
you want to convolve two lists of
numbers you treat them like their
coefficients of two polynomials you
sample those polynomials at enough
outputs
multiply those samples pointwise
and then solve the system to recover the
coefficients as a sneaky back Doorway to
find the convolution and as I've stated
it so far at least some of you could
rightfully complain grant that is an
idiotic plan because for one thing just
calculating all these samples for one of
the polynomials we know already takes on
the order of N squared operations not to
mention solving that system is certainly
going to be computationally as difficult
as just doing the convolution in the
first place so like sure we have this
connection between multiplication and
convolutions but all of the complexity
happens in translating from one
Viewpoint to the other
but there is a trick and those of you
who know about Fourier transforms and
the fft algorithm might see where this
is going if you're unfamiliar with these
topics what I'm about to say might seem
completely out of the blue just know
that there are certain paths you could
have walked in math that make this more
of an expected step
basically the idea is that we have a
freedom of choice here if instead of
evaluating at some arbitrary set of
inputs like 0 1 2 3 on and on you choose
to evaluate on a very specially selected
set of complex numbers specifically the
ones that sit evenly spaced on the unit
circle what are known as the roots of
unity this gives us a friendlier system
the basic idea is that by finding a
number where taking its powers falls
into this cycling pattern it means that
the system we generate is going to have
a lot of redundancy in the different
terms that you're calculating and by
being clever about how you leverage that
redundancy you can save yourself a lot
of work
this set of outputs that I've written
has a special name it's called the
Discrete Fourier transform of the
coefficients and if you want to learn
more I actually did another lecture for
that same Julia MIT class all about
Discrete Fourier transforms and there's
also a really excellent video on the
channel reducible talking about the fast
Fourier transform which is an algorithm
for computing these more quickly also
veritasium recently did a really good
video on ffts so you've got lots of
options and that fast algorithm really
is the point for us again because of all
this redundancy there exists a method to
go from the coefficients to all of these
outputs where instead of doing on the
order of N squared operations you do on
the order of n times the log of n
operations which is much much better as
you scale to Big lists and importantly
this fft algorithm goes both ways it
also lets you go from the outputs to the
coefficients though bringing it all
together let's look back at our
algorithm outline now we can say
whenever you're given two long lists of
numbers then you want to take their
convolution first compute the fast
Fourier transform of each one of them
which in the back of your mind you can
just think of as treating them like
they're the coefficients of a polynomial
and evaluating it at a very specially
selected set of points then multiply
together the two results that you just
got Point wise which is nice and fast
and then do an inverse fast Fourier
transform and what that gives you is the
sneaky back Doorway to compute the
convolution that we were looking for but
this time it only involves o of n log n
operations
that's really cool to me this very
specific context where convolutions show
up multiplying two polynomials opens the
doors for an algorithm that's relevant
everywhere else where convolutions might
come up if you want to add probability
distributions to some large image
processing whatever it might be and I
just think that's such a good example of
why you should be excited when you see
some operation or Concept in math show
up in a lot of seemingly unrelated areas
if you want a little homework here's
something that's fun to think about
explain why when you multiply two
different numbers just ordinary
multiplication the way we all learn in
elementary school what you're doing is
basically a convolution between the
digits of those numbers there's some
added steps with carries and the like
but the core step is a convolution
in light of the existence of a fast
algorithm what that means is if you have
two very large integers then there
exists a way to find their product
that's faster than the method we learn
in elementary school that instead of
requiring o of N squared operations only
requires o of n log n which doesn't even
feel like it should be possible the
catch is that before this is actually
useful in practice your numbers would
have to be absolutely monstrous but
still it's cool that such an algorithm
exists
and next up we'll turn our attention to
the continuous case with a special focus
on probability distributions
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]